on this Frosty Friday night bundle up as
a major storm barrels towards the east a
dangerous deep freeze descends on
Alberta it's completely um appalling
that we that any of us should be out
here while some BC drivers face an
uphill
battle the Middle East crisis becomes
more volatile the US and UK's strikes on
hoi Rebels was done in partnership with
our allies to defend themselves the
concerns about Canada's support and the
threat of Revenge debunking deep fakes
and disinformation the lies infiltrating
taiwan's election campaign and
redefining trust fund give it give it
give it away why this billionaire is
handing over her huge inheritance to
strangers global national with far
Asser good even evening thanks for
joining us tonight Canadians are facing
bitter cold damaging winds and blinding
snow as severe weather sweeps across our
country there are weather warnings and
watches in every Province and territory
some areas feel like a bone chilling
minus 50° another powerful January storm
is expected to bring strong winds to the
maritimes this weekend but first it'll
Pummel Ontario and Quebec and we're
going to have more on that in just a
moment but we're going to begin out west
where the temperatures are plummeting
parts of Metro Vancouver are turned into
sheets of ice with several buses sliding
to a stop right in the middle of the
street the severe cold snap isn't only
affecting BC though the cold is even
more excruciating in the Prairies Nea
Gera on the winter weather in the
west abandoned
cars
left right and Center drivers in the
Metro van Vancouver area dodging
obstacles on the road Friday after a
chaotic commute the night before when
snowfall and black ice snarled
traffic the whole road is just
ice it hasn't been salted some
residential roads like this section in
Burnaby hadn't been salted leading to
multiple crashes in Richmond RCMP say
luckily no one was hurt in a 17 car
pileup the gridlock prompting warnings
to to stay off the roads if possible
just stay home it's that bad very very
icy
on heavy winds in areas like abbottford
causing power outages as much of BC is
in the grip of Arctic air with extreme
cold temperatures lower than minus 45 in
some parts it's mean and nasty right now
we don't have power and yeah we cannot
work and sometimes just walking because
the the wind is is really bad a historic
deep freeze is settling in Alberta
Environment Canada issued a provincewide
extreme cold warning with the coldest
temperatures expected Saturday morning
near minus 50 with the wind chills some
of the lowest in nearly 50 years it's
completely um appalling that we that any
of us should be out here then having to
suffer under these conditions there's
people that are sick that are disabled
um in wheelchairs they're not motorized
and and yet they have to survive there
is high stress in Edmonton where those
in homeless encampments face eviction as
temperatures dip to dangerous
lows snow is tapering off in much of
Saskatchewan after the first major
snowfall of the Season dumped up to 15
cm back in BC the chaos from the sudden
but not unexpected snowstorm has some
blaming governments for not doing enough
in a statement The Province said its
Crews were well prepared and out in full
force but some of the spun out Vehicles
didn't have proper tires we also reached
out to some of the hardest hit
municipalities and local officials had a
similar response reminding drivers to be
prepared far nethu gcha in bnab BBC
thanks nethu and as we mentioned Ontario
and Quebec are bracing for another storm
it looks like it's already started
meteorologist Anthony Farnell our chief
meteorologist here at Global News is
braving the elements out in Toronto
Anthony what can we expect from the
latest storm well the snow has begun in
Earnest and it is coming down heavily
far and this really is a front loaded
system what I mean by that a wall of
snow with almost no visibility amounting
to about 5 cm per hour and that is the
concern on this Friday evening that all
this snow is going to fall and the plows
won't be able to keep up with it so
anybody on the roads has to deal with
these white out conditions now it's
sticking to just about everything there
is winds gusting 60 to 80
kmph and the temperature clim climes
tonight so it all switches over to rain
now for areas to the east there are
warnings there are winter storm warnings
in Quebec now for the maritimes uh it's
a different story it's a southerly wind
that could cause 90 to 100 kilm perh
gust and that along with astronomical
High Tides could create some surge
issues there's a storm surge warning for
St John and some of these areas have
been hit hard by Coastal erosion already
earlier this week from a similar storm
so it continues winter making a comeback
and then comes the cold far and it's
going to be around for a while all that
Western cold is headed
east oh stay warm Anthony Anthony
Farnell our Global News meteorologist
thank you so much for that winter
weather is also wreaking havoc in the
US in Iowa the weather is mucking up
election pitches for us Republican
presidential candidates days before the
first caucuses several campaign events
were cancelled due to blizzard
conditions and temperatures as low Asus
29 in Illinois hundreds of flights were
grounded or diverted from Chicago's
O'Hare Airport this just some of the
more than 5,000 that were cancelled or
delayed across the us
today now to the Middle East where
tensions are escalating beyond the
crisis in Gaza this is after a series of
joint British American strikes on houie
Rebels late Thursday it's all in
retaliation to the iran-backed groups
attacks on ships traveling in the Red
Sea since
November these are some of the places
that saw air strikes overnight though
it's not entirely clear what other areas
in Yemen were hit according to the US
missiles and aircraft struck 60 Targets
in 16 locations the US defense secretary
says a combination of houy air defense
systems logistical hubs and Facilities
storing drones and weapons were
hit we will make sure that we respond to
hoies that they continue to outrageous
behavior along with our
allies
no IR does not want to war with
us now despite those assurances from the
US president many fear this strike could
signal another step towards a wider
conflict Jackson prosco
reports the Coalition air strikes came
after repeated warnings to the houthi
opening an unexpected new front in the
Middle East we said very loud and clear
there would be consequences and last
night there were for weeks commercial
ships passing through the Red Sea have
come under attack houthi militants say
they're targeting any vessel with links
to Israel in solidarity with the
Palestinian people global trade is
upended as cargo ships steer
clear the US and UK call their air
strikes an act of self-defense I think
the impetus is mostly economic because
we've seen shipping rates for containers
go up 50% and we've seen most companies
just decide not to go go through the Suz
and the Red Sea back by Iran the houthi
sit on one side of a ceasefire in
Yemen's long-running Civil War which
could be derailed by the air strikes and
may not cause the militants to change
course in the Red Sea warns Canada's
former ambassador to Saudi Arabia it
feeds their narrative that they're
standing up against the West if it
escalates even further they become the
victim as they get International and
international sympathy they've played
this card many times over the year the
risk of retaliation remains High the
houthis insist American and British
interests in the region are now
legitimate targets Washington and London
say they will not hesitate to take
further action if needed our aim is very
clear it's to deescalate tensions and to
restore stability to the region this is
a piece of The Wider conflict the US had
been so desperate to avoid it is not the
direct conflict with Iran that still
looms as a possibility States across the
Gulf region are now on on high alert
calling for restraint from all sides
Jackson prosco Global News
Washington so who are the houis they are
a militia group based in Yemen and led
by Abdul Malik Al Hui the group emerged
in the 1990s but Rose to prominence in
2014 when Rebels fought Yemen's
government They seized the capital SAA
and control of much of Northern Yemen
the houi ideology is built around
opposition to Israel and the United
States at one point they were poorly
organized their Arsenal now includes
cruise and ballistic missiles and long
range drones and houis have now become
part of the soall Iranian Le access of
resistance which includes Hamas in Gaza
and Hezbollah in
Lebanon no Canadian equipment was
involved in the attack on the huis but
this country did play a small role prime
minister Justin Trudeau says Canada
supported precisely targeted strikes the
conservatives have endorsed the response
but as David Bon reports the NDP is
concerned Canada's backing an escalation
of military activity in a volatile
region prime minister Justin Trudeau
said Canada's decision to join the
Coalition military Mission flowed from
Canada's commitment to a rules-based
international order the hooes were
endangering uh lives and livelihoods not
just uh of shipping in the region uh but
of people relying on the humanitarian
supports the uh the commercial uh Goods
that are transiting through that
extraordinarily important International
Waterway um their actions could not
continue pushing Common Sense the
official opposition agreed they're
operating basically as a a Tran backed
pirate outfit that is uh threatening
International
Security but the NDP says while the
houthis are indeed a dangerous Group
which has committed war crimes and
terrorism it was disappointed in
Canada's decision we need to to think
about what is the strategy to make sure
that that Canada is playing a role that
results in more peace around the world
that results in more peace in the Middle
East and I and I don't think what we saw
um yesterday is is something that's
going to result in that no Canadian
military assets were used in Thursday's
attacks but the Canadian Armed Forces
has deployed three staff officers to the
Coalition Mission they assisted with
planning and intelligence analysis that
gives us a window into what's going on
militarily and it also sets us up for
Success when we again because I'm
certain we're going to do it contribute
frigs to the region you heard Trudeau
taking great care today to characterize
the mission precise targeted narrow
limited that's certainly a recognition
that many Canadians and perhaps many MPS
in Trudeau's own caucus do not want to
see an escalation of attacks and do not
want to see more casualties far David
aen in Ottawa thank you David now during
his appearance in gal Ontario the Prime
Minister was also asked about where
Canada stands on South Africa's case
against Israel at the international
court of justice where it's alleged
Israel is perpetrating a genocide in
Gaza but our wholehearted support of the
IG and its
processes does not mean uh that we
support the premise of uh the case
brought forward by South
Africa the premise of that case was
challenged today in the heg as Israel
delivered its defense to the United
Nations highest court as Crystal ganing
Reports Israel rejected the allegations
while accusing South Africa of grossly
distorting the
facts the entirety of its case hinges on
a deliberately curated
decontextualized and manipulative
description of the reality of current
hostilities tal Becker stood before the
international Court of Justice and ask
that it dismiss South Africa's
application Israel's position is that
there is no genocide and no grounds for
a provisional order to Halt military
operations Israeli officials say there
is suffering which they called
heart-wrenching and
tragic and becomes magnified by Hamas
operating out of Civilian infrastructure
including hospitals you will see a
militant going into K's hospital with an
RPG Hamas fired at IDE of forces from
near and from within the K hospital at
chifa hospital gaza's largest Hamas
managed operations from a closed off
area here you can see an opening to the
tunnel that ran for hundreds of meters
directly under the hospital in every
single hospital that the IDF has
searched in Gaza it has found evidence
of Hamas military use by highlight in
these and other examples Israel
attempted to show its Targets in Gaza
are legitimate Israel is committed as it
must be to comply with the law but it
does so in the face of hamas's utter
contempt for the law South Africa's
Justice Minister says Israel failed to
disprove their case and we believe and
stand very confident that those facts
the law still are in violation of the
genocide convention it's not known when
the icj could come back with the
decision Crystal Gan in Global News
London Canada's top Soldier General
Wayne a is retiring after 40 years of
service a has been chief of the defense
staff since 2021 responsible for the
command and control of Canada's Armed
Forces as well as military strategy he
attended Military College in Ontario and
British Columbia and he served in Cyprus
Croatia Bosnia Korea and twice in
Afghanistan prime minister Justin
Trudeau announced a will retire this
summer and he thanked him for his
unwavering service to Canada a warning
to check your pantry tonight coming up
the popular snacks that are being
recalled and
why quicker Canada's issued a nationwide
voluntary recall of some of its most
popular granola bars and cereals due to
potential exposure to salmonella the
recall effects nearly 40 products with
expiry dates between January 11th and
September 7th of this year a full list
can be found on the Canadian food
inspection agency's website Quaker says
out of an abundance of caution customers
should dispose of the products or return
them for a
refund ahead Taiwan cracks down on deep
fakes influencing its key election
for from Deep fakes to artificial
intelligence it's getting harder and
harder to determine what is actually
real a flood of disinformation is
hitting voters in Taiwan ahead of
tomorrow's presidential election now
some researchers say Taiwan is more
impacted by disinformation from Beyond
its borders than anywhere else in the
world and it's overwhelmingly aimed at
candidates opposed by China the race is
close between two people divided over
relations with China Jeff simple reports
on how Taiwan is trying to crack down on
a sophisticated campaign of misleading
content in taiwan's election campaign
voters can't always believe their
eyes that's presidential candidate
William lie his Democratic Progressive
Party or DPP rejects Bing and wants
closer ties with the
west but in this YouTube video lie
praises the pro-china opposition
claiming they represent taiwan's
mainstream view turns out this video is
a fake
produced with artificial intelligence
using a clip from this actual press
conference where lie condemned his
Rivals we are seeing the use of
generative AI in what we think or might
suspect should be CCP linked information
operations this Canadian in Taiwan works
for double Think Lab Global News visited
their office last year it's one of many
Taiwanese groups dedicated to
factchecking and debunking
disinformation and in this election
campaign they've had their handsful with
fake videos and posts a lot of these
content managers are faking accounts a
lot of these accounts are coming out of
Cambodia China and Malaysia um which are
trying to manipulate opinion the posts
claim lie who opposes Beijing hasn't
paid his taxes and that his running mate
is actually American with hopes of
creating confusion or just generating a
a a general view that the DPP is utterly
corrupt and should be uh taken out out
of office this Canadian Security analyst
in Taiwan says the government is
cracking down on Chinese interference
using a new law the anti-infiltration
ACT Taiwanese authorities arrested a
journalist who wrote for this website
after she allegedly published a fake
opinion poll claiming the pro Beijing
party was ahead they also arrested this
independent candidate on suspicion she
received funds from China sparking
outcry from some civil liberties groups
so it's it's a challenge it always leads
criticism even when action is warranted
and always compels us to make sure that
we're not overreaching uh in uh trying
to defend ourselves against that which
we do not want to become he says
taiwan's experience fighting election
interference offers hard lessons for
other democracies including Canada Jeff
simple Global News
Toronto inheritance giveaway why an
Austrian ays is handing off her family's
Fortune
as the sing goes the rich are getting
richer in Canada the wealthiest 1% of
families are estimated to control nearly
25% of this country's wealth that's up
5% from the start of the century a trend
that's been seen around the world many
have attempted to tackle this growing
wealth Gap through politics but one
Austrian ays is now putting her money
where her mouth is by pledging to Shell
out Millions from her own inheritance
mro
reports I am only here because I'm am
richer than you it was an audacious
statement sure but Marina englehorn was
just getting
started you see in the years since the
31-year-old Austrian made this speech
she's inherited money 1 million 2
million Scrooge McDuck type money her
family founded the BASF chemical and
Pharma company she's now worth billions
but she sees the world through very
unscr like glasses and I'm telling you
the money is there we Super Rich could
have saved the world had we wanted
to we have the money we can afford it
but we don't she announced this week 50
random austrians would form a council to
decide how to spend €25 million I'd like
to see your most expensive stamp and no
they can't keep it or spend it
frivolously it isn't an asset anymore
more he's mailed it in fact her only
caveat it has to benefit society and
that's only the start because she plans
on giving away 90% of her wealth yeah
I'm really uh excited to see how this
all unfolds like englehorn Clare trach
came into her wealth through the lottery
of life and sees income inequality as a
massive problem the former
microbiologist is now dedicated to
philanthropy full-time and as part of a
group called patriotic millionaires she
she agrees with angle horn that a wealth
tax is desperately needed and a wealth
tax at that level would not have any
impact on like my life you know I would
still be able to take nice vacations
like it it's not going to change my my
lifestyle or the lifestyle of other
wealthy folks it just means that our
wealth would continue to grow slightly
slower than it currently does and the
99% who don't have the wealth are likely
okay with that micro Global News Toronto
and that's global national for this
Friday night I'm faren aser on behalf of
our whole crew I want to thank you for
spending part of your evening with us
take a look at your Canada tonight it is
the sunnd dog near elrose Saskatchewan
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and take care of each other good
night
[Music]